nous voilà à présent
la conf de presse de sony qui va
commencer dans quelques instants et j'ai
emmené comme la suisse ça va vous seriez
les cocons retrait du lait comme j'ai
pris mon soulier vous ne voyez pas les
causes du style mais ce n'est pas un
appareil de sony mais c'est pas grave ça
marche quand même groupe de presse de
sony je sais pas trop ce qui va être
annoncé
intéressante là pour l'instant on est
juste récupérer une information qui est
très intéressante et services comprend
je veux le dire c'est la connexion au
wifi si on voulait vous connecter venez
à l'ifa dépêchez vous c'est maintenant
voilà donc des nouveautés du goût des
jolies à plein de choses aujourd'hui et
l'ifa il ya eu un truc de 500 à l'heure
il ya sonny ya plein de trucs des
comptes c'est cool quoi là ça va ça va
très bientôt
écoute moi j'adore ça
talât délivrer la d league
[Musique]
- c'est un gosse
on est sur le stand de sony donc là tout
s'installe aujourd'hui mise en place la
compagne de tout à l'heure demain
ouverture au public donc sa ferme dans
très peu de temps et en fait c'est cool
parce que connaissent et sony un gym à
génial audio ici l'on a il ya plein de
choses il ya bien évidemment le
smartphone ce qui nous emmène aussi
aujourd'hui mais il ya vachement ajouté
vous retrouvez tout l'univers de ceux
nés ici
beh man could vachement intéressant est
justement une nouvelle xperia 5
extérieur pike comme vous voulez qui est
dans l'absolu en tout cas qui galère
parce que je n'ai pas encore testé
qu'elle a vraiment cool propositions
intéressantes et surtout qui vient se
positionner juste en dessous d'experian
peut-être plus grand public vous ne
verrez ce que vous en pensez en bons
commentaires que je me pose c'est que on
en parle avec 5 milliard de sony comme
ça je ne dirai plus vendus on n'avait
que sa meilleure de l'équipe saunier ça
va super bonjour à tous nouveauté xperia
cinq ans ni comment x trail à 5 espagne
atime comme on dit on dit en français on
dit expérience 500 appareils plus
logique
aujourd'hui on a annoncé 1
nouveau membre de la famille premium des
smartphones xperia qui vient compléter
donc le xperia arc xperia 5 qui est un
smartphone avec un écran
plus compact surtout un design plus
compact avec une prise en main
extrêmement facile ce qui fait 68 mm de
largeur toujours avec un écran 21 9e
voilà c'est vraiment le moto2 cette
année en politique rien et l'exploit ya
cinq ça c'est assumé chez sony on se
muscle 21/9 et on va faire un pour la
prise en main est de 2 pour l'expérience
visuelle
oui exactement qui est juste parfaite
pour des contenus cinéma on attaque bien
sûr ce qu'ils sont ce qu'on a de mieux
en terme de d'autofocus puisqu'on a
exactement la même fonction qu'on a sur
nos appareils à pc mais également plein
format donc le suivi de l'oeil ouais
enfin jusqu'à 10 images en rafale avec
un suivi
l'exposition et autofocus ça c'est quand
même suivi de l'oeil donc c'est quand
même canon d'avoir ça sur un smartphone
et en dernier point donc vous avez un
produit qui va avoir un écran full hd
oled le tout dernier processeur x1 donc
vous avez un traitement d'image qui est
juste parfait pour preuve ce produit là
qui se veut être plus grand public avec
différentes couleurs se toucher une
cible plus large que le xperia qui est
un produit plutôt te regarde on voit
qu'on a design très allongée ça c'est
cool pour la prise en main c'est
vachement bien
on a à peu près la même chose que son
expert vous avez ce côté ici bouton de
volume le capteur d'empreintes digitales
et toujours le bouton alors le capteur
d'empreintes digitales fait office de
bouton donc quand on veut déverrouiller
mais bon pas l'absolue pourquoi pas
comme ça le fait d'avoir positionner la
caméra là ça fonctionne aussi noble soit
on sera prêt on est on est sur un
smartphone qui est assez long mais qui
en tout cas je trouve est vachement cool
en termes de prise en main
quand on fait on reprend ce qui marche
sur l'xperia one star hier 1 et on
enlève le côté un petit peu application
signer alta pour aller filmer et on se
retrouve se reproduire de plus grand
public alors l'application signer halte
à elle est toujours là et elles mêmes ua
aussi doit absolument pas question donc
le format 21/9 est aussi là pour ça
qu'elle est toujours là
c'est un bon point puisqu'on l'a
amélioré et des nouvelles
fonctionnalités qu'on a intégré
donc on continue énormément sur cette
partie cinéma donc l'application savez
le cinéma pro confiné alta étant la
marque
oui à nos caméras c'est vrai hollywood
vient et c'est donc aussi un des
éléments qu'on veut cultiver chez sony
étant un grand acteur du cinéma
d'accord ok alors en termes de pertes
j'ai vu qu'on a connu un qualcomm 155 à
l'intérieur la salle rigole c'est ça on
est si giga de ram là même la partie
mémoire est également extensible
donc voilà on a un produit qui est
plutôt bien plutôt bien ce paquet qui va
venir répondre à des besoins qui sont
bien plus large on va dire que ce que
faisait le xperia dione sur une cible
plutôt du connaisseur
ce produit sortira à 799 euros oui il
sort
mois d'octobre mais avant ça dès lundi
en fait on organise une précommande meco
et on va intégrer donc ce produit là qui
est le wf mix marque 3 oui pour les
personnes qui voudront à précommander
leur produit mais ils auront la chance
de recevoir le wmx marque 3 0
donc c'est le fait d'avoir intégré la
partie mobile dans l'organisation sony
c'est aussi une traduction ici avec ses
précommandes de vouloir proposer ce qui
est de mieux en terme de dio vidéo pour
pas pour les consommateurs et les fans
de la marque
je crois que tu bosses le faites pas
vous bossez antec légal sans papa l'on
dit on essaye alors qu'en fait comment
tu fais je crois le lancement c'est lui
à toutes et à tous et geoffroy de
prendre il en est actuellement à l'ifa
de berlin où sony a dévoilé son nouveau
smartphone raid nautique ouvert il ya
cinq ans une blonde fait partie
maintenant il faut que tu me fais de la
pub pastilles à quitter le jeu c'est
notamment ce n'est pas dans notre sens
que tu le fais aussi ménage avec
téléphone dans cette maladie c'est quoi
il ya les bons et toi tu films indiens
moi tu sais j'ai l'habitude d'un pas
l'habitude bah oui choque comme certains
professionnels
exactement c'est le mot je suis le héros
professionnels aguerris professionnels
professionnel jouffroy qui sont
enfreintes frandroid.com il fut prise
come to my websites d'espoir était alors
le trading des centaines de photos
appareil photo qui marchent aussi très
bon souvenir puisque on mardi auprès de
vue strict
donc c'est un triple capteurs c'est
comme si c'est nécessaire à 3 x 12 x 16
mm 1 26 min 21 52 donc en 16 mm grand
angle 26 mm capteur principal
ouais et ensuite de 50 2 qui fait un
zoom x 2 en optique où on a qui va vous
permettre d'avoir notamment des effets
bloqué sur les portraits décalés donc on
a aussi de la réduction de bruit qu'on
applique pour les scènes en basse
lumière
oui alors là il ya un certain nombre de
fonctionnalités et dont suivi de la u
dont je vous parlais en introduction ou
roux qui est vraiment la fonctionnalité
que tous les parents attendent pour
capter leurs enfants pour la rentrée
ça sent le vécu et ça permet de faire
des effectivement des photos qui sont
inégalées et au niveau autonomie
qu'est-ce qu'on est comme batterie
intérieur alors on a une patrie je veux
pas dire de bêtises de 3300 millan pairs
d'accor et des poussières à 1330
d'accord à vérifier sur la sueur sur la
fiche bug ça lasse donc entre un et deux
jours d'autonomie sur l'envoi votre
utilisation
gamepad à peu près pour jouer une
application dédiée là aussi avec des
petites applications comme ça qu'ils
viennent de notre écosystème qui vont
vous permettre de jouer et d'améliorer
votre expérience de jeu
d'accord on peut changer sa voix on peut
aller tout petit sur youtube sans sortir
de son jeu le jeu par ailleurs le jeu
fortnight est compatible avec la
dualshock 4 cuil je vous invite aussi à
le tester
user la manette directement sur votre
smartphone ça permettra de libérer la
télé la console dont l'un certain nombre
d'applications qui viennent renforcer le
message est la proposition
divertissement que les xperia 5 va
proposer au sommet troqué dos rond il
vraiment se reproduit du grand public
comment ça se passe aujourd'hui pour
celui d'une convenu ce mark von pour
sony sur la partie smartphone on a
marqué un virage avec le xperia on va
dire depuis le 1er avril l'activité
mobile est intégré au sein de sony
europe et le xperia un fort de ce
nouveau naming est venu simplifier on va
dire en notre gamme de smartphones et on
vient désormais et qui a d'ailleurs
plutôt bien marché on a plutôt envie de
nous
en termes de ventes et en termes de
parts de marché donc on est plutôt
contents du résultat du xperia et on
vient consolider cette première étape
avec un ex-paria 5 qui se veut plus
grand public sur un segment premium qui
est aujourd'hui le segment sur lequel on
veut batailler en voilà pour cette vidéo
sur sony c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on
en reparlera prochainement se testera
ultérieurement ce xperia 5 je pense
qu'on va avoir un produit plutôt
intéressant qui va être un peu dans la
lignée de xperia one pour confirmer
grâce à plus tard en tout cas c'est
plutôt cool
l'innovation toujours du côté de chez
sony là on parle de smartphones ya plein
de choses hyper cool motion très grand
fan de leur casque w/h mix m3 du
téléviseur incroyable vraiment une
marque qui à 360 degrés qui a été
vraiment hyper hyper hyper hyper cool on
en reparlera de l'état me dire ce que
vous en pensez comment le trouvez-vous
ce xperia ça qu'est ce que vous pensez
qui pourrait vous convenir qu'il
pourrait marcher est-ce que vous pensez
que ça smartphone qui peut aider à sony
a continué sa progression sur le mobile
vous marquez tout ça on va encore monter
à la cour d honneur pas l'ensemble très
bientôt sur ce fait des gros bisous les
gros becs et à bientôt
[Musique]